me anything I couldn't get really sure
quite a spiritual experience this is the
is a had yes
good morning guys I'm not gonna lie I'm
a bit sick right now but I'm gonna pull
my together and we're gonna get out into
Islamabad got some guys we're gonna meet
up with some cold locals met them last
night
very interesting guys that are gonna get
us into into the guts of this city yeah
get a shower some breakfast I'll be
better and we'll do this okay here with
Omar yeah and Umar where we off to you
guys
[Music]
this is the iconic mosque of Islamabad
right yeah here we are coming up to a
massive square this was this was built
by the Saudis when was it built seventy
[Music]
guys what's the reason for for washing
before
[Music]
so the guys went to pray and I sat at
the back of the mosque observing firstly
the architecture here is absolutely
stunning and uplifting
I admire many things about Islam there
is a very strong feeling of unity that
everyone is connected through something
much greater than themselves there is
purpose in the regularity of prayer and
hospitality
most Muslims I've met in the world have
always been very open and welcoming
quite a spiritual experience you guys
yeah even for me
and I don't know what's going on it's
very common yeah it's a new city and it
has a grid pattern and if you compare it
to other cities in Pakistan it's very
orderly and modern yeah wide lanes roads
and there's there's regions right you
call I like F something and what is it
called like well if six F seven sectors
Salam alayka you guys have taken a video
is that cool I'm from the US yeah thank
you first first time I love it it's very
interesting
you can see it for yourself in China for
distillation yes exactly and that's why
I'm making these videos so I show other
people this experience all right how are
you man good brother I'm sorry I'm just
late so cars late yeah it's okay
we met last night yeah you're the wealth
of knowledge yeah thank you very much
Islamabad yeah a lot of security here
I've seen yeah this is the red zone so
this is where the diplomats yeah
we run that with big book yeah in 1/16
Islam but was announced as I gave it a
long time okay yeah so it's mostly
government workers yeah so what about
you guys do you like living here in the
city yeah exactly this is the capital of
the country and obviously it is we
really enjoy to live but you don't want
to be in like the big buzzing Karachi or
Lahore ya garage is also very great and
lore is also very cool
but you know the environmental issues of
the cities like smog and all that yes
traffic issues and secure yeah it's just
peaceful this is very enjoyable tomorrow
when did you guys stop using plastic
bags long few months ago I guess plastic
bags are
[Music]
so look at that chocolate selection
that's solid I'd say one of the easier
things whatever bag no plastic bags you
know that yeah so now they got these but
they don't work so up he doesn't put my
bag almost a month ago three months ago
oh yeah Omar just told me yeah
okay shukriya I got a simple it's for
all of us chocolate so one of the cool
things about traveling Pakistan is the
language barrier in the cities most
people speak English it's easy to get by
in English everything's written in
English and okay it's always cool to
speak the other language but let's be
real it is V not British colony yes of
course but let's be real like you're not
gonna learn so it makes it super easy to
navigate and travel yeah what's the
spelling that's cool and that's just um
you know this pewter total even Tina a
distributed or disputed hotel yeah I
mean because that's from the top of the
hotel you can see almost all of the red
zone so that's where due to a security
they just you know gosh yeah yeah stop
the construction and all that so you
were telling me Amara the US embassy
here the workers make three times as
much money as you
it's my life secure here with you guys
yeah we're all about who you're with
yeah we were in secretary f6 three it's
not the most vbi be an elite sector of
the wealthiest neighborhood there are
elite people when you say lead people
does that mean remote meal
no no elite people mean the rich people
okay but are they rich people here
mostly in government you can see that a
lot of barbed wire and guns yeah you
know I've seen a lot of guns here a lot
of guys security yeah but you know a lot
of businesses with spherical our homes
they're bored as hell - they're never
doing anything right yeah Salam alaikum
this looks to be an I like a nice
restaurant
you guys making a movie yeah but I'm
making drama
day 20 days 69 wow that's that's a drama
in itself that's a lot of work then
provides the famous words of a director
so this is one of the nicer zones in the
city
where you gonna take us uh you said the
slums there's yeah let's go have we seen
all the rich neighborhood yes I think we
have seen that we've seen similar again
let's go to the slums I want to see the
contrast oh I think it's hard for the
Western view to understand at least it's
been a surprise yeah it's been a
surprise for me to see that environment
right in bin Laden was yeah two hours
from Paris
yeah but that was time when yeah and
wave of the terrorism that was very
rough one right now the dub it is the
Pakistan is all about the peace
capability and there is no such thing as
terrorism because there are terrorists
and down now I think that they have
eliminated almost 99% of four of the
terrorists oh yeah you can say that this
is the most VVIP sector and just in the
middle of this sector is the people
lives like you know shouldn't life
in the middle of that in the middle of
that those people are basically servants
you can see them okay and they work in
their houses also like VIP people
they're all Christian yeah there are all
croissants no Muslims living and the
colonies colonies of the dead
that's a lot of Christians are the
underclass here yeah what's the history
to that you know okay wow that's a
different world
yeah then what we just saw and the rich
the rich stuff is right behind it right
yeah I think that when these people when
they apply for reserve for America or
some other country
yeah they have a very successful ratio
rather than convert to us it really
exactly is they're crazy because they're
Christians
Islamophobia right we are not allowed so
you're an educated guy you have a
university degree and it's harder for
you to get a visa that these guys they
have a cool billiards table
Salam alaikum
they all have jobs yeah hold em up
thankfully no please capture this now
people their affiliate playing playing
cards I've been in quite often there's
like a tight community
yeah but appeal to them this house this
is all about rich people yeah this side
of the sector yeah but on the left side
yeah it's all about slums and guys do
you think there's much else up here not
really yeah when you go deep inside just
like da Oh wall city of Lahore the
church over there yeah Full Gospel yeah
assembly Church Islamabad is that the
only Christian Church in the city no
holding the city there is also there is
also a very busy I'd the church Salam
alaykoum well I don't say that here
right because it's Christian no
understand that yeah okay okay
Never Say Never nice repair situation so
I give the Islamic greeting even though
the Christians know the meaning of the
Islamic greeting is that but I could
may Allah bless you may Allah bless you
may God bless you guys want some popcorn
yes you're okay you know there's no
popcorn
okay the Australian Government's here to
[Music]
it's okay Christmas interesting so can
you tell if somebody is Christian just
by looking at them oh yeah
how like like 99% of the cases we can
look at their color and there's a way to
talk don't we to talk that is a little
bit different than the others
but we totally we being a Muslim we are
totally comfortable with them okay so
these ladies yeah how do you know if
someone's Christian by the way they talk
I like in the oh they're the way this
talk and the way they like you know
there is a little bit okay a little bit
difference see you can tell I'm not
Muslim no you sure
we can only say that you are an American
[Music]
once he tried to photo shoot here huh
yeah and you know it's depicted that man
they bring them inside and it is that
the wire was taking pictures this is the
is I had yes yeah so Pakistani
intelligence which are very good best of
the world all these intelligence in
Delhi they know everything
yeah do you feel like they have a tight
lock on society they know answers I'd
lock like they have a very tight log on
almost every every factor of the society
[Music]
so guys what is this what are we going
into here what would you say is the
coolest thing about Pakistan what gets
you excited about Pakistan these days
like in the past there were some issues
like you know there was not very much
civility in boxing but right now I must
say that all of the world should come to
Pakistan for the tourism purpose the
government has taken great initiatives
more tourism like you you know that you
came on the Italian passport like
directly by Ibiza by applying in the U
visa full full disclosure guys nobody's
paying me anything tax then you get me I
don't want it today I don't want to be
controlled with my content a list I knew
there is no issues no no I'm an American
here I'm an Italian pati are that's
beautiful let's go what is this I don't
wanna man knocks on window is of
Independence no no no memory of you know
baguette on
Ayane said that you are so beautiful so
we are so terrified and scared of Johnny
sense you like Charlie I'm not like you
know you liked you like Josh I like
Julia yeah I am her father
I've been trying to keep this out of the
video but I'm just gonna let it go
hi every single place I go yeah they say
this it's not the first time I was
called
all right guys
[Music]
[Applause]
that's it
Islamabad quiet place spacious place
calm place especially compared to Lahore
cool guys that was really interesting
learning through them and tomorrow
tomorrow is off to the mat I'm off to
the mountains oh excuse me
about an hour flight up into some of the
most beautiful peaks in the world and
we'll continue their good night like and
subscribe if you want to support this
channel hit the notification bell to be
the first to see my next video many more
videos about Pakistan and other parts of
the world coming soon